[Music]
how are you guys doing before we start
the video I think it's apt and right for
me to emphasize the fact that now we
have started the first 10 days
of which are in fact the most important
days of the Islamic calendar to the
extent where the Prophet Muhammad s
wasallam himself mentioned in a Hadith
that there are no days in fact that good
deeds is better than performing good
deeds in these days than these 10 days
of they asked
him not even
jih he said not even
J except for somebody who goes with his
wealth and his health and doesn't come
back with any of that and so the
opportunity that we're going to present
for you today is for you to give
charity to the most poor and
disenfranchised people in the entire
world in fact you've seen the suffering
not just of the people in Palestine we
can't forget also the brothers and
sisters in Syria yes we can't forget
those people and we can't forget our
brothers and sisters in Yemen and we've
seen the Salvation in Yemen and there
are Food Packs designed for countries
like these which I'm going to you can
click the link below £ 440 imagine the
the kind of alleviation of pain that you
can contribute to by clicking this link
I would say click it now it will only
take 30 seconds 40 seconds of your time
and imagine the rewards that you'll get
recently the far right people like Tommy
Robinson and others who have been trying
to strategically avoid me because of
their cowardice and others have
organized a protest and it's not the
first protest they organized of course
there was one that they organized and
they invited Ali da went with him and
they attacked us in fact it was like a
20 on two attack a very famous One some
time ago because it takes 20 men to take
someone like me down in fact they
couldn't even bring me uh down but this
is something that they tried to do and
so these Thugs who are the far right
have now come out again and they've got
seveny olds in the street curse cursing
and using derogatory and pejorative
language with not just the permission
but the blessing of their parents let's
take look at the clip and come back and
react in
[Applause]
kind so there you have it guys I you can
see yourself you've got kids in the
streets and I feel very sorry for them
and sympathetic to their parents I mean
why would the a a caring and loving
parent put a kid in a street to uh you
know espouse profanity for the world to
see it's actually embarrassing and it's
humiliating and it's sad for the kids
this is a kind of abuse on the child
actually that you are subjecting them to
this now people all over the world are
going to be attacking those children
because they see them as attacking a
religion or something like that or being
or using swear words and you have
subjected them to this attack that's one
thing then you have all these other
chants that are happening because these
people the far right and this must be
understood are not just
anti-muslim okay they're not just
anti-muslim they've been anti-ethnic for
the longest of time there's videos of
Tommy Robinson where he's walking around
and saying he's upset with the aesthetic
of London he what is of the aesthetic
that you're upset with clearly the major
differential between then and now is a
racial differential it's not just a
religious
one and you see with Tommy Robinson and
His likes people that corroborate and
collaborate with him people like David
Aon who's got a face not Even's mother
would love let's take a look at this guy
fabricating things all the time lying
and being
dishonest for example recently I saw a
clip of theirs that was getting tens of
hundreds of thousands of views on
Twitter in fact where they are alleging
that I am saying something which I'm
saying the exact opposite of let's take
a look at the
clips but if something is going to be
because of something you need something
in Arabic yeah you need
like or something something Saab in this
is
because there's nothing like that so it
doesn't say that this is because they
believe in Jesus is the son of God and
doesn't say that so they the the B of
the burden of proof is upon the one
who's making the claim if they're saying
that it's because they this is what they
actually say this is what we hear they
say the reason why you have to fight
them is because they are Jews and
Christians so we say but that's not what
the aah says the Ayah just
says so it could be start starting with
a new sentence it's doesn't say this is
because they are you have to fight them
because of that reason you see the point
so that nalf this point that Ali was
just mentioning I don't know where he
was but within the script now how would
you respond to this
aah this aah does not really require
response because it's not does not prove
the fact that there is is fighting
towards combatants it all it proves is
that you can fight or you should fight
those Empires around you or those H
around you which are Jew or Christian
like the Roman Empire and like the
Persian Empire until they give the Juda
that's fine that we already know Islam
allows and then the how the Hess of that
is in the Hadith the three uh the the
three uh options that they're given
either you give the jizya or you do this
or you do that
yeah we we're not apologetic about that
point that's that is truth but we're not
saying that this doesn't prove that what
they can kill who the combatants doesn't
say that it just means that you can
fight the other powers which are
Christian and Jewish that the the hakum
the the power centers are Christian and
Jewish so he put on Twitter he cut it up
manipulatively and he literally made me
say something the opposite of which I
was saying so I was saying that the
Quran doesn't say that we should fight
Jews and Christians because of their
religion and he made it so that I said
some say that we should fight Jews and
Christians because of their religion
because the fact that they're Jews and
Christians and he made it seem as if I
was saying the opposite of what I was
saying by removing some would say such
and such and it's shocking that you know
you have all these fools yes all these
idiots you know low brow unintellectual
uneducated people of the right wing far
right you know applauding him and
clapping and saying yes and and this is
what we're seeing dishonesty you are
liars in order to beat us in a fight you
need 20 men in order to be in an
argument you have to change what we say
I'm sorry to say if that's what you're
presenting to the table then you are the
lowest and most unworthy opponents I've
ever had the displeasure of facing
because you keep cheating keep cheating
the system and I want to announce to the
public that in fact I'm taking Tommy
Robinson to court himself for defamation
of character saying things I didn't say
that's what you have to say and now
you're going to have to defend yourself
along with Douglas Murray and a
multitude of other English or British
papers in a court of
law you're going to have to do that now
and put your money where your mouth is
so that's another thing that we're doing
with them but let me just give you a
question for the for the far right and
we have seen by the way that the far
right now have started to divide we've
seen Nigel farage and Tommy Robinson and
others be more on the pro-israel
position okay we've seen Nick Griffin
and Jada Franson and others we've seen
them kind of more on a patriotic idea
and not thinking about Israel in fact
they have an antithetical attitude
towards the genocide in Palestine for
example and the reason I think for that
is because of funding and this is
something that the these so to say
workingclass farri right you know
support base need to understand that
you're being played and used you are
being played and used let's take a look
at low key describe the funding that the
far right have we look for instance at
an organization known as Middle East
Forum founded by Daniel P now the
director of this think tank is Greg
Roman a former employee of the Israeli
foreign Ministry and the Israeli defense
Ministry they received the between 2010
and 20111 around $4 million from Capital
um from donor's capital a fund which is
largely used to funnel money for the
cult Brothers the billionaire oil barers
of the United States now the midle Forum
funded G welders they also funded Tommy
Robinson the free Tommy campaign was
funded by the Middle East Forum they
paid his legal fees and in fact on top
of that Lucy Brown a former employee of
Tommy Robinson came forward and said
that he was receiving £10,000 per month
from Robert schilman who was Robert
schillman he was formerly on the board
of directors for the friends of the
Israel Defense Forces Tommy Robinson has
gone to the West Bank the occupied West
Bank wore an idft t-shirt and posed with
the gun on top of an Israeli tank he has
even said in the situation of War he
would fight for Israel
there's a reason why someone like Tommy
Robinson and Nigel farage used to be
thinking about you know Britain first if
you like and uh you know the the ethnic
issues and racial issues
before and now you're seeing a new thing
coming to Frey which is a pro-israel I
mean they they're supporting Israel
pound-for-pound maybe even more than
they are supporting Britain and a good
explanation for that from some people
may argue some people may argue is
because they're being paid money to do
so as we can see with low Kei said that
that's a feasible inference to the best
explanation and these right-wing guys
who are working class right-wing people
far right they are falling forward and
being used by the likes of Tomy Robinson
who's enjoying a very lavish lifestyle
at their expense and they're being
embarrassed in front of the great
population where their own children now
are looked at as uncs in the streets uh
some some uneducated ones and this is
the reality of the situation and I just
want to say one thing um and this is
what I'll conclude with it seems to me
that what the protest was trying to call
for Was the removal or deportation as we
see in many of the comments Deport him
get rid of him although you guys talk
about freedom of speech but put that to
the side of Muslim people of ethnic
people of people of non why indigenous
uh background or
complexion let me ask a question and be
let's be honest about this for a second
let me ask
question let's say we remove these
people and that what is going to
represent Britain is your are your
demographic the demographic of far right
let's say Tommy Robinson supporters how
many doctors are in that demographic
medical doctors how many Engineers are
in that demographic I would like to know
how many professors and intellectuals
are in that
demographic if we were to look and ask
the people in that protest how many of
you have finished a degree in a
university in fact to be not to be fous
but how many of you have even done GC so
to say so how many of you do you think
they are do you think you that
demographic do you think that
demographic is capable of running a
country let's be
honest the answer is a resanding no the
unfortunate truth is that most of these
people are not just sociological
failures but they are ideological
failures in life you are ideological
failures in life and you need us you
need Muslim people you need ethnic
people you need people who you would
consider the other you need us to
justify your own failure that's the
psychological aspect of it and you know
it you know it that you are a failure
okay you're an educational a physical
and an and an ideological failure and
instead of owning that failure and
trying to change yourself you need a
scapegoat yes to make yourself feel
better about yourself don't you and
that's why you have
this unhealthy fixation and obsession
with the Muslim Community of Britain
with blacks and ethnics and pakistanis
and Indians or whatever me that's why
you have this unhealthy Obsession
because for the most part you know it's
not just them taking your jobs it's them
reminding you of your
failure think about that